From investing in Uber and expanding in Silicon Valley to investing in New York real estate,...
...including its 44% stake in the nearly 9-billion-dollar redevelopment project in Manhattan...
...and over in Asia, last year, Qatari's investment fund...
...bought Singapore's Asia Square Tower One from Black Rock.
The 2.5-billion-dollar deal was the largest office transaction in Singapore's history.
And these investments really just scratch the surface...
...of where the world's richest country per capita is putting its cash.
As Qatar diversifies its investments across industries and continents,...
..the tiny country is showing little signs of slowing down in its mission...
...to buy some of the world's biggest assets.